yo what up it's Desi Hollow check me out
at the bootle Kev podcast hey before we
get into the interview we want to give a
shout out to our family over at Imperial
extraction they're bringing you today's
episode um and check this out if you
want a free 2 G thca loaded pre-roll yes
that's right you can get one of these
for free you don't have to buy anything
all you got to do is go to Imperial
extraction. use the promo code boot leg
and they're going to send you one of
these for free look premium glass tip
time Imperial extraction. comom promo
code bootleg you're going to get a free
2 G THC Diamond loaded pre-roll that's 1
and half gram of that premium top shell
flow and a half a gram of THC diamonds
loaded up to your door for free just pay
shipping let's get into the
interview bootle C podcast special guest
in here Desi Hollow represent Oceanside
man Oceanside in the house what up Kev
man I'm I'm chilling uh been a long time
man for sure you got oh I remember when
I seen you last um we was at uh we was
at a event and you was like on your
phone cuz you had placed to beted Oh and
it was it looked like you was down bad
though you know what you're right that
was
um that was a Cypress Moreno spot yeah
in La it was do do man's event right
yeah there was a beted I had like 10
grand riding on a college game
and I don't remember if I think I might
have I think they pulled it out for me
but I definitely the whole time I was I
had 10 grand on that game and that [__]
sucked that [__] was stressful I'm glad
I got over that part of my life yeah you
you were sweating over there oh yeah
that's crazy yeah it was like a college
I don't even watch college football bro
but I I just be using my homies picks
and I put 10 10 bands on a game and I've
never been so in tune to a football game
and I forgot who was playing it was was
like might have been UCLA or something I
don't know but I don't remember if I won
that bet I think I won it I think I'd
remember more if I lost it cuz I know my
big losses I I could point at the game
and say [__] Mike White from the Jets
beating the Bengals two years ago 15
bands out the door but you know I've won
enough I'm off the gambling now little
spending money a little bit I do a
little bit here and there you know I put
a little bit out there but I dude there
was like a during that period there's
like a twoyear stretch during the
pandemic where I was [__] leveraging
some bread on [__] I can't control which
is a bad habit to have by the way if
you'd like to do the same thing go to
mybookie.com and use the promo code
bootleg and sign up and you uh you might
get a first deposit bonus up to
$1,000 sh out my bookie but yeah no that
was that that I do remember that yeah I
don't I wasn't even in present at the
event cuz I was so like I know I was
like Hey k k man look bro like yeah n
but uh hey uh how's everything man
everything's good everything is on the
up um I just released that um project in
the video with the funk coton the funk
yeah um I just released that and um
independently uh as my first independent
drop and it's you know it's a video
corrupt and then I also dropped yes uh
my game plan was to drop the album with
the visual with corrupt um and then
following that my whole rollup plan was
just my music videos I have been
shooting music videos um my my I guess
my plan is not like in Industry like a
industry roll out but it's kind of
like like a consistent like consistency
type of roll out it's a different format
than well you've been like uh diving in
the last couple of years into kind of
bringing back this old
school like G Funk [__] that's like
missing from the game yeah I I think
right now is a good time for the type of
music I'm making because you don't
really like hear that anymore no for
sure it's different it stands out and
it's something that like the West Coast
was known for and I's making it I feel
like I have a chance to kind of be the
person that's you know gets to like
bring in that that second wind of of
funk and um you know I'm I'm doing my
best but it's it's it's you know it's
catching on I see people starting to
like find out about me that were like
man I used to listen to this type of
sound when I was younger growing up and
it was the same with me you know I I
grew up on the sound and and now I'm
creating it yeah for you when did you
kind of decide to like go that route
yeah
uh I think like 3 years ago I dropped my
first project that was just all Funk
right and it was called
um was called uh cot in the funk or no
not cot in the funk I think that's a new
one right no what is the first one
called cuz we had one nation under the
funk was the one before this before that
one was can you handle the funk um that
was my first project where where I just
did only funk you know but I had always
I had always like you know mess with
funk and and you know was accustomed to
it from just growing up on it but I
never really like had a body of work
that was dedicated to just that sound
you know and you've been working with
like some Legends like you had a record
with sugarfree I saw sugarfree um
dubc U been working with little Rob
shout out to Little Rob yeah shout out
to little BR man he's definitely a solid
one that that has always been a
supporter for sure and like I've been
seeing since you've been doing this like
you've been going up like I see you
getting bookings and [__] I see you
doing car shows yeah no I've been doing
a lot of shows and but my whole thing is
that I really want to do like a a
successful tour um for this project I
I've never been like on on tour or
really had like a booking SP dates and
stuff yeah right I've never had like a a
a booking agent really put together like
some tour dates for me so right now I'm
in the middle of getting that done dope
congrats yeah thank you yeah so so for
you what so you've worked with some
Legends man who's been the coolest guy
to kind of like hang with and like you
know cuz they all they all have their
own um like personalities and for me
it's like I'm I'm a I'm a a younger of a
younger generation so I kind of have to
like I don't know like speak accordingly
but just you know know like who I'm
talking to cuz little little Rob the way
I talk to little Rob is different than
how I talk to like corrupt or or dubc
you know um but you know I I got love
for them all and they've all showed love
but by far Little Rob has has been
someone that's been like well you guys
are I mean Oceanside and San Diego are
not the same but you got to get you got
to go through Oceanside to get to
[__] San Diego if you're in LA and
they're very they're very even though
you guys are very different M A lot of
people kind of just like my homie Ben
Ben uh I don't know if you know Ben fly
he's he's from oce side but when he
talks to people about where he's from
who don't understand California he just
says San Diego because it's easier to
say that than Oceanside cuz if you say
Oceanside you got to be like oh where's
that and you know it's about an hour uh
north of s you know so you guys are like
for little Rob little Rob's kind of like
one of
the pillars of San Diego hip hop if not
the goat of it like it's like J felony
him like there's Rob Stone like there's
guys but like little Rob to me is the
most
like longevity dude that kind of
represents sou of La the most if that
makes sense yeah I think the word for
little Rob would be like iconic because
sure he's an icon um when you think
about like Cho rap he's he's you know's
he's the face he's like the Jay-Z of it
right which is you know that's a big
thing um for sure so yeah no much much
flowers and props to Little Rob yeah n
so for you do you ever get frustrated
that Oceanside has yet to kind of cuz
it's now I feel like you're doing such a
good job of making sure people know like
Oceanside is Oceanside like and you have
a sound which every place needs a sound
MH you know what I'm saying but like
being from Oceanside you guys get
confused and but punched in San Diego a
lot you know what I mean is that
something that gets frustrating CU
you're like no we're our own thing over
here like it's a whole different
place for me I just um I you know I just
tell people on promotion side you know I
have love for like a lot of artists from
San Diego and I spent a lot of time down
there and um yeah and you know o side's
beautiful too yeah but for the most part
you know there's like a lot of
similarities and um it's it's just all
love you know with me but but ocean side
is definitely it its own thing um so a
lot of military folks there yeah yeah
and right now it's a lot of like
gentrification and like remodeling so we
we see a lot of tourists we see a lot of
like um prices going up we see we see a
lot of things changing right now so it's
becoming a hot spot too yeah it is for
people to like go vacate there or like
move there like I have hell of people I
know from Arizona like yo you ever heard
of Ocean Side thinking about living
there and I'm like really yeah people
will come on vacation I've met somebody
and said they were on vacation I was
like out here you know but but they're
starting to get more and more things
that attract tourists out there so you
know it's good and bad um but I always
try to paint the picture of you know how
it was for me growing up in Ocean Side
because at the end of the day every city
is going to like get gentrified it's
going to get you know it's going to
change you know nothing stays the same
so my job is just to paint you know what
I know of you're yeah you're you're rep
you're a represent ation of your city so
you got your experience there you got to
share with the world yeah hey let's stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our folks at my bookie damn it all
right look NFL playoffs are going down
Super Bowl's on the way go to my bookie
right now and let's get in on the action
not to mention right now is the time to
sign up all right if you sign up with
the promo code bootleg mybookie.ag head
over there right now you're going to get
your um first deposit bonus up to
$11,000 all right that means you put in
in that promo code you put in your money
they're going to match it they're going
to get you right up to
$1,000 um and uh I don't care what
you're into same game parlays uh I don't
care if you want to get down with the uh
uh over unders you know what I'm saying
some of the prop bets whatever it is my
bookie is going to get you situated all
right so go to
mybookie.ag get in on this action all
right I just hit a crazy they got this
thing where you could put three teams on
a teaser and they give you plus 133 if
it's a thre teaser woo look do that
tomorrow do that next weekend on these
NFL games trust me you know what you're
doing you should be able to hit that all
right pretty good odds on it too all
right so go to mybookie.ag sign up with
the promo code bootleg and get that
first deposit bonus up to $1,000 right
now also want to give a shout out to our
folks at bluechew listen man it's
getting cold outside it's cold as hell
outside out here in LA right now you see
me I got the jacket on it's cold it's
cuffing season all right if if you got a
rectile dysfunction uh if you're dealing
with stress at work if your dick ain't
[__] it's all good blueo got you all
right let me tell you about blueo a lot
of people always are asking me does
blueo work yes it works like a charm all
right go to blu.com use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up and they're
going to show you that it works because
they're going to send you a month for
free that's right a month supply of blue
for free all you got to do is pay $5
shipping all right blue . use the promo
code bootleg same active ingredient as
Viagra and Calis but it comes in a
chewable form and it's delivered right
to your door in a very discreet
packaging you don't have to go to the
doctors anymore to talk about why your
dicks you know underperforming you know
and look I'mma Be Honest the blue Chu is
kind of like you know when Barry Bonds
hit 70 home runs hey look bro if you
want to impress abroad get you a blue
Chu you go all night bro your dick ain't
never been harder blu.com promo code
bootleg get a free month supply right
now all right all you got to do is pay
shipping let's get back to the interview
um it's dope man so like obviously you
grew up listening to old school hip hop
the funk [__] like for you like was
there a record or a moment that like you
kind of realized like oh [__] like I
could
really bring this [__] back low key if I
really like lean into this a lot more
more cuz you weren't always making funk
music I think when I first met you you
were making more like traditional rap
[__] you know yeah more more like
lyrical like boombap trap right right
right right uh for me I mean my whole
reason behind make like interest in
becoming an artist was listening to like
artists such as DJ Quick yeah U Nate Dog
um you know a DPG uh so you know I I was
I was into like that West Coast sound
but it took me a little bit for it took
me a while to kind of like grasp how I
was going to sound especially like a lot
of my hooks are like sang um and stacked
um so I had to learn how to stack my
vocal I had to learn what sounded good
and what didn't um because I did a lot
of like test runs like for this last
album I did like 150 songs to to get it
down to the 14 that are on the album
[__] um mainly because like sometimes
I'll be like all right I have this good
Melody and when I lay it I am not don't
have the capacity to be able to project
my vocal in that way so then that songs
ends up being trash you know you got put
someone on yeah yes and no because for
me it's like I like to do a lot of
things myself find you your Nate Dog you
know you got to find you your Nate Dog
well I mean I sing on a lot of my hooks
but it's like some sometimes the thing
doesn't come out how you think it's
going to come out you know and I was
telling myself that before somebody else
is like yo that sounds like [__] you
know I'm I'm my biggest critic for sure
it's funny cuz I always say that I'm
always like dog like why
why don't we hear I say this about like
Legends in La you know cuz I'm like man
why aren't La rappers making the [__]
that like the CL like there's a reason
why the chronic and and all these
records are Classics like why not do
just more of that in 2024 like take that
sound and just make it the sound again
and so when you're doing what you're
doing and I see it like actually working
for you and like I see people who don't
know you posting your [__] all the time
and I'm like oh [__] that's dope that
the sound at least is it's that OG sound
is resonating because it's missing like
nobody is I don't think got got the
balls to be like man I'm going to do
this OG West Coast [__] and make it
modern and make it Fly
and just push the sound cuz the sound is
is is is is is still popping people are
still listening to those old school
records yeah you yeah especially
overseas for sure especially overseas
you know and my whole go-to with
Worldwide with corrupt was that you know
it would it would resonate with overseas
and like I know Japan's Got a huge
following like they love the LA [__] in
Japan yeah you see you see like uh the
the the clothing style the the the cars
you know have you got booked over there
yet no but you know this year I'm hoping
yeah I'm hoping especially I want to get
um on that low rider tour too um I don't
know if you're familiar with like Low
Rider magazine of course they've been
doing the card shows forever yeah I
think you're doing or you already did
did you already do the Super Show in
Phoenix I've done it twice and then I've
done Vegas twice um and then I'm also
doing this year I'm going to be in
Colorado for a super show them shits are
fun dude yeah and like all them dudes is
there to have fun so it's like you know
like some rap shows you know how it is
when you go to like a rap show and
people don't know who you are they
really they kind of got your nose up at
you a little bit you go to a car show
everybody there is just like oh this is
great there's a concert happening let's
enjoy this yeah because other than that
it's just like it's it's good to look at
the cars but you know a little
entertainment you know yeah especially
if you have a dope set which which my
the music I make just ties in really
well with the L your visuals like you're
you got a lot of cars in your visuals
and [__] yeah the cars I I try to put as
much Cali culture in my videos as I can
um cuz like I said man like you don't
see a lot of that no more for sure you
don't man so it's dope to see it like uh
for you is has there been um anybody who
you've noticed checking you out or have
liked the photo or or left a comment or
dm'd you where you're just like oh [__]
this person I'm on their radar that's
crazy um I
mean yes but I mean I would say yes to
like certain posts that are like I did
of me but I've done collabs with like
sugarfree dubc and um and corrupt and
it's like you know their their peers
will comment and chime in on like who um
like who's the craziest guy you're just
like I mean there's like a handful like
Mac 10 just last post I did with corrupt
it was like Mac 10 lazy bone um Richie
Rich shout out to Richie Rich Man shout
out to the Bay um yeah but it was it was
like there was some big names on there
that I just was like okay that's that's
that's cool you know Ma 10 um I'm a big
fan of ma 10 oh for sure I think Ma one
of the most slept on [__] ever
somehow like when we talk about West
Coast grad somehow he slips to the
cracks cuz he's one of them ones bro
like he backy boie forood so like tough
like when I think ofle wood that's the
first I think Ma 10's face yeah I think
Englewood I think a ma
10 and that's it I mean shout out to RI
there's other but I think as a kid I
think Ma 10 bro like I'm like [__] he
was he was I never would have thought of
Engle wood and except for when Tupac
said it on California Love then I was
like Engle wood always up to no good
okay what's that place but n Shout out
to uh to to M 10 yeah that'd be a crazy
collab because he's he's back to makeing
music again and I think he did uh I want
to say the last record he dropped was
Carr it was very I'm trying to think he
was on the show man and it was like so
cool to talk to him cuz oh yeah yeah
yeah it was like about like cars right
yeah but M 10's a legend bro and he's
got some real classic albums and
Westside Connection is one of the I mean
that album the first album bow down oh
yeah it's on the mantle up there yeah
that that was a powerful rap group for
sure for sure West Side connection um uh
you know DPG of course shout out to dog
pound shout out to uh corrupt corrupt is
a cool ass [__] too yeah yeah
and he has some funky ass [__] too like
if you think about like some of his
singles and [__] like like like he had
that sound bro shout out to corrupt man
I miss I just miss old school like La
hip-hop so I'm glad that you're like or
just west coast hip-hop I don't use the
word La cuz you're obviously an
Oceanside but just the West Coast sound
is like it's it's it's going it's like I
got to listen to 20-year-old records to
hear the [__] I love right you know what
I'm saying so it's good to hear what
you're doing you're keeping that [__]
alive and I I think the fans
are relating to it you know cuz it's
obviously working for you yeah yeah it's
working but it's like it's at my own
pace you know how how however much like
work I put into it is it's going to like
it's going to be my outcome you know or
however much like financially however
much I put into it financially it's
going to be my outcome as well and
you're strictly Indie oh yeah so you
know I fund everything I fund like the
videos the just everything you know so
it's like once you get into the business
mindset you kind of like it I'm not
going to lie it kind of like goes into
the the writing process so then when I
write a record it's like okay I didn't
write something that's going to sell but
at the same time it has to be true to me
um so being able being able to like um
be manage everything and stuff like that
and and have like a business mindset um
it's definitely transferred into the
music yeah that's dope yeah I mean if
you're handling everything you're
handling your own videos you now you're
like okay well cuz I'm sure you have to
pay for some of these features but
you'll know okay I I know I could get
this back yeah yeah yeah it's just an
investment you know and um and it's like
for what you do it would you have to do
those features because for you to like
have a record with corrupt making old
school like hip-hop [__] like that that
[__] is that shit's fire yeah but but at
the end of the day each feature goes to
the next feature if you know what I mean
say I just work with corrupt you know
now it's like open me to a whole another
now everybody now when you reach out you
be like it's easier to to you know I got
a little bit of like mhm you got a
little pull now a little bit of pull a
little bit of weight under my name now
so hey want to give a shout out to our
family at King pal baby want to shout
out to King pal man they've been holding
us down for a minute now and um I feel
like my life kind of changed once I
started smoking out of King Palms
because it's so smooth man it's organic
there's no tobacco no nicotine it's a
natural leaf uh and the best part about
these King poms they come in so many
flavors this is the latest flavor that
I'm on right now it's the pink lemonade
now it's dope it's a turpine infused tip
you get to stuff your flour in it light
it up you squeeze that tip and you get
hit with a burst of flavor and it is SCH
smacking all right so let me tell you
about King pom we hooked up to hook you
up if you go to King pom.com right now
you can order anything from the website
if you want a box of these if you want a
grinder if you want an ashtray if you
want some of these you know what I mean
whatever you need some of that Lemon
Haze you know I know the holidays just
pass but you like that pumpkin cream pie
they got that too all right whatever you
need it's half off half off 50% off when
you go to King pom.com and use the promo
code bootleg 50% off not to mention if
you're in town you're driving around
wherever you're at I don't care where
you're from where you're watching this
from go to the 7-Eleven they got King
pom go to your local smoke shop they got
King pom the industry leader of Natural
Tobacco nicotine free smoking experience
and trust me when I say you got to [__]
with them bootleg is the promo code at
King pom.com get half off also want to
give a shout out to odd Soxs can we get
some odd
Soxs look at all these [__] odd Soxs
we got here oh my
God first of all the modellos are hidden
all right so look if y'all don't know
man odd Soxs just celebrated uh their
10year anniversary I was out in Tampa
with them they're are family they're are
are just our dogs for real for real and
um they are the most comfortable socks
in the
world Listen the most comfortable socks
in the world if you guys ever see me
anywhere I'll always have these on or
the white version of the basics to me
these are like walking on clouds and if
you're into I don't know
Monopoly you know I don't know maybe you
are you're a [__] a Pez guy who the
[__] a Pez guy uh SpongeBob maybe
you're an alcoholic maybe you like beer
so much so I'm first of all I love these
Modello socks they're fly as [__] all
right uh I don't know which ones I like
more Corona Modello I think I'm going go
with the Modell socks and I think I like
Modell more than Corona um Bubblicious
man um how about the Power Rangers
whatever you're into they got it I mean
look WWE
cocacola uh buritos uh I mean Godfather
they got all the licenses all right odd
Soxs is changing the game the most
comfortable socks in the world I want
you to try out some odd Soxs save 20%
right now don't forget they got the
underwear too save 20% right now when
you go to odd Soxs official.com and use
the promo code
bootleg and uh we want to say shout out
to them and congrats to their 10e
anniversary our partners our family at
odd Sox oh these are GI Joe draws I'mma
take these home let's get back to the
interview who you want to work with next
Mac 10 Mac 10 yeah or Warren G that'll
be hard Warren G lives I don't want to
say where he lives but he lives down
there not not down where you are but he
lives on the way there yeah yeah yeah
yeah shout out to Warren I'm sure that's
easy man uh not as easy as it as it
sounds but it's like well Warren G's
like a real family man and he's a by the
way his Instagram's lit cuz he' be
barbecuing hella meats that [__]
is a grill afficionado I know it looks
great he has his own sauce looks great
he has his own like dry rub I think I
think it's sniffing Griffin I think what
it's called whatever it is he he's he's
got it going but Warren G is like you
know he was active a couple of years ago
he put a record out with t Allis sign uh
maybe two or three years ago so yeah I
mean no I follow him you know I see him
in the booth um and he's doing a lot of
these old school shows that's the other
thing is like when you do these car
shows now yeah I run into them you can
run into them I run into war I mean I've
met War already I met a lot of artists
already but I you know it's not like I'm
going like hey let's let's work
magic I think that'd be hard you get
like MC Magic talkbox hook on one of
your records yeah me him me and him have
gone back and forth before um MC Magic
cuz I I done like a handful of shows
with him I get tied in a lot with like
shows with like Baby Bash Little Rob so
I'm in the the whole like I see them a
lot you know that whole circle it's a
car culture [__] cuz you're making like
that you know you're Mak like yeah so
what what's uh the albums out uh
obviously corrupts on the album anybody
El on the album um corrupts on the
album um Mitch slicks on the album hey
shout out to Mitch slick San Diego
Legend and then pilo's on the album pilo
fire did he do the beat or he just do
the verse he did the beat and then we
recorded the song together and it was
fun bro it was it was working with him
is fun bro like usually when I work with
artists it's like damn we're in our own
size of the room we're riding [__]
literally together we got we're sitting
down we got a mic we going back and
forth he great you know it's like I
never recorded like that before was
working with pilo like was that
something like where he reached out to
you did you reach out to him how'd that
work that's a crazy thing bro and this
music [__] is nuts because like I had a
shoot check this out I had a shoot in
Hollywood with inhale which is Nate Dog
son okay yeah yep yep and we were
shooting at some house out there and I
went to the liquor store and P walks in
the liquor store and I'm just like what
the [__] is that P I get my stuff and
then I go outside of my car and and he
what do you know he's passing me I'm
like yo P what up what up what up but I
had met him previously at an Empire
party when I was signed with Empire
years
before um so then after I seen him that
time we end up following each other and
then one day he just reached out and
said yo man let's like you're do let's
see what we can do yeah which was a a
big thing for me because like when I
look at like the status that he has he's
up there you know so for me it's like
man like of course let's let's create
you know um so then I went and I met up
with him the first time I met up with
him like five times we made like three
songs hard and none of them were a
until like I gave it a little bit of
time and then I came back to a studio I
was like yo I want to make something for
my album um I want it to be funky but I
don't want it to I want you to still be
turned up do what you do that bass sound
and then we created that record and then
I I put this record called hotel lobby
um on my album that he produced and we
created together fire that's dope but
he's solid though man I big shout out to
P just you know with the help with
everything you know and he's doing big
things he's killing it uh shout out to
Mitch shout out to strong arm steady too
he's one of the mo out out in San Diego
so M for sure man all right so look the
album is out uh I suggest anybody who's
watching this who haven't heard of you
if you love classic West Coast hip hop
this guy's bringing the sound back in
his own way in a modern dope way
bringing the funk back
um and there's a tour coming soon you
definitely you're doing all kind of car
shows you said you're doing Colorado
soon yeah yeah we got some shows coming
up um but I'm just going to try to put a
tour together with with with the dates
as soon as possible possible you know
but he you're doing some dope [__] man
it's good to see you know your growth
and uh I'm glad that you found something
that I feel like was missing cuz you're
doing it I I when I see your [__] I'm
like man this the [__] this [__]
should have been doing this ill [__]
like so it's just glad I'm just glad to
see someone keeping that [__] alive and
it's working out yeah no it's it's um
cuz you ain't like a new artist you're
like you've been around a minute bro so
like for for you to like kind of keep
stick stay stay with it until you were
able to find right right right it's the
consist and and just being relevant you
know like a lot of people like don't
understand how to even like work certain
things such as like social media or you
know like different platforms you know
that they should be utilizing in order
to be like seen you know you got all
that it's nowadays you have to wear more
hats as an independent artist than ever
yeah not only do you have to go make the
music but you have to promote the music
and you have to know how to promote the
music that's the own their own skill
alone you to be honest with you you
really got to learn everything like how
to record yourself how to edit some
video everything bro everything yeah if
you're going to be independent and even
if you ain't you're crazy if you don't
learn all of that anyway you should be
able to kind of save as much money as
you can here there right because like
they say knowledge is power you know if
you know how to do editing videos or you
know how to record yourself that's
that's two people that you don't two
people you don't have to pay right right
right that's what Russ always says Russ
is like I edit or I edit he used to edit
his
videos he records mixes Masters and
makes his own beats those are a lot of
things that cost money out in the game
so so man keep killing it bro go uh the
album's called cotton the funk right
cotton the funk yeah it's out right now
you can go stream it um YouTube go check
out all his videos uh you got videos
with some some big dogs so you know just
go dive into what this guy's doing Desi
Hollow shout out to Oceanside man um if
we go to Oceanside what's the one
restaurant you're taking me to man if we
go to Oceanside I'm going to take you to
this spot called
um it depends if if you like um like uh
twisty Loos and and like what the [__]
is that you don't like to Loos what's
that it's like a um is it Mexican food
yeah it's a mexan Mexican spot called
Ricos and they have like uh toasty Locos
is like a big plate of it's like a bunch
of different stuff on it that sounds
like some motion siiz [__] it's no man
it's you know toasted Lo toasty Locos
toasty Loco yeah that sounds like a rap
group dog that sounds like they were
assigned to high power records back in
so see you got to try it so we're
definitely going there for sure all
right there we go my guy I appreciate
you pulling up yeah of course bro can we
show some love to our family at hardine
man shout out to harden man look if
you're in Vegas you got to pull up you
got to say take me to harden right now I
need to go to harden they're going to
take you they're going to get you
situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it's just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
vegas.com and when you're in Vegas make
sure you pull up to harden baby